I'm visiting an inn in Massachusetts
that's been run by a dysfunctional
couple I love you so much but you suck
as a business partner he's lost I have
no idea what I'm doing here and she's
lost it just wanted to keep it together
tonight and with the staff suffering as
well what's the worst thing she's ever
done to you smack me on the back of the
head I'm not even sure if I can get
through to them the whole operation is
screwed what do you think we should do
close come on ni
nestled in the heart of Scenic New
England lies the small industrial town
of Southbridge
Massachusetts it's home to the Vienna
Inn and Restaurant husband and wife
Jonathan and Lisa cro have owned and
operated the Inn since buying the
property back in the year
200000 Jonathan had this crazy idea of
creating the Vienna as an Austrian
restaurant and bed and breakfast she
said have you been drinking I said no
not yet we try to transport people and
to give them that feeling of being in
Vienna without having to fly
there when people come in and they stay
here for the first time they think that
Jonathan and Lisa are very gracious host
Charming the perfect married couple but
if you dig a little bit deeper and you
stay a little bit longer find out it's
quite a different story Lisa is an
emotional person she does get upset
often she will just you know explode and
she can't help but be upset she's over
the
top my beautiful wife my boss sometimes
she's not so nice to me why do you
always have to dress like a goddamn like
bum there has been a time where I called
her a psycho [__] cuz she was being a
psycho [__] clean up man I'm done with
this
I don't feel like Lisa is authentic when
she's crying I don't feel like she ever
means
[Music]
it Jonathan and Lisa live in a room at
the end you can hear them screaming at
each other and you can hear it in the
dining room so there's no boundaries
they'll come down after the shift at the
end of the night and they'll have cigars
have some drinks the environment can
quickly become unprofessional she'll go
up to a table and ask them about like
their sex lives you are good looking we
don't get that many locals at the Vienna
there's like a lot of things that people
think in town about the Vienna and I
think it's become a little
taboo you have uh those rumors going
around people say oh the Vienna they're
all swingers it's a big brothel it's
just it's just ridiculous it's
ridiculous that being said we're very
friendly people very
[Music]
friendly people from the outside think
that VI is doing very well and we're
very prosperous but somewhere in there
we're losing they're dragging us down
with them and if they want us to help
them they they need to help
us the Vienna is our home has been for
13 plus
years and you know it's hanging by a
[Music]
thread
and this 5:30 at T 5 walking right in we
want to be ready
for this place my God what happened to
him he didn't last very long did
he found our
cat huh bloody hell dead cat the Cabbage
isn't that
funny good morning hello welcome nice to
meet you it's good to see you to Gordon
first name is Melissa Melissa good
morning how are you how are you Lisa C
Lisa nice to see you you don't look very
happy I
do it's my resting face wow um yes
welcome to the Vienna so happy to be
here well happened to the
cat poor thing cat got run over oh I see
and you got it stuffed for Halloween
right actually better to see you now
right um yeah love the attire by the way
thank you everyone wears this wow how
much are the outfits about $300 $400
$300 average you know they get their own
I mean they're their own dresses you
know oh you buy your own uniforms yes
they do stop it it we do well they have
them for many years and it reminds them
to not gain
weight wow so who designed the place
well uh my husband and I and whose idea
was it to buy it uh my husband so it
wasn't yours it was not my idea IDE
actually very much against it wow uh uh
why were you against it it was very
overwhelming I had two small children
but probably uh after I lost my mind the
first
year I think we started to get a hang of
it and who's Austrian are you my
husband's half Austrian and polish right
I I'm not nearly as exotic I'm very
American right and he's the chef right
so he runs the restaurant kitchen and
you run the in correct and whose idea
was the violins on the table mine where
did that come from that was actually
from an estate sale down the street a
dead man's violin no why not I don't
want to sit across a table with my wife
and look at a dead man's violin well bit
freaky know I don't know what would you
rather look at when you see the Vienna
her who's her uh my wife oh your wife
yes but you have to have something to
make up that white
space what would you suggest uh my wife
you're going to put her on the table
that's kind of scandalous I am so
[__] confused used Dead Man's violin
what about some
flowers fluty H is this place always as
clustered as
this and who's that there a Prussian
family of course that was um Frederick
that uh their family all was
murdered Ur are hungry yes wow so dead
man's violin and murder on the wall um
great story to uh encourage a nice warm
welcoming dinner so um why don't I check
in upstairs you can do that right now
yes please you want thank you
wow wow interesting indeed a clutter
your bedroom's over here rocking chair
where's that from that's actually the
first piece I ever refinished wow so
you're quite an antique
hoarder room service oh room service
come in holy mackerel now what we have
here is some pull Bo Tre yes right and
then you have a little celer root right
on top wow and what's that a little
parsley excellent um what take one would
you like me to have one yeah of course
there three three pieces excellent sure
thank you thank you for sharing you're
welcome oh hold on wait wait let me put
a little bit of the garish on that you
want me to have that well yeah we'll
have a little
piece
mhm what did you think of that by the
way celer root really don't like it the
pull Bo maybe just a bit more soft wow
and what did you think of that I think
it's a nice little surprise for people
when they come in to uh liven up their
appetite ball was very watery it was
very watery I didn't that the bread was
soggy soaking wet soggy from the celery
route thank you enjoy your stay please
pass on my uh comments to the chef I
definitely
will there we go
oh dear okay wow and who designed these
bedrooms I designed everything you
design mm I wallpapered it as well
seriously what's this that's a another
closet what you mean I don't have a
closet in my bedroom that's a closet
that we have because there's an area
over here for guests to use but where am
I going to hang my clothes right over
here but
you don't need an entire closet so if
you need clothes out of your closet you
come in my bedroom do you have the key
on you I do can I see inside I just I'm
a bit freaked with locked doors in my
bedroom go yeah I'm sorry okay thank you
it's right here oh was there
wow just my closet holy crap stop it
stop it seriously oh my
stuff it's like a garage cell in a
closet that's why we keep a lock on it
I've got no interest in wearing the
garments but thank you are you sure I'm
I'm positive 100% positive bloody
hell what's the price of this room this
one is $220
$220 cor yeah and I have to share my
wardrobe with the owner but what's
through this room here well that
actually goes to my bedroom so do you
just walk in when you need to get some
clothes from here no but from your
bedroom to my bedroom well I only do
that once or twice a
week and what's
this wow it's a an antique purse that
was actually found in the house and we
thought it was really neat to uh be able
to have as for that's a toothbrush
holder in case you decide to take it
along with you that's a toothbrush
holder or you could stick tampons in
there if you really wanted
to we do usually have those oh they're
not in there right now there you go an
old lady's case mhm just trying to think
of clever ideas to make this feel like a
historic
in
historic it's definitely historic oh
bloody hell how old is that you need
that no I just fascinated to see what's
in my basket thank you for that oh dear
everything looks dated I mean First
Impressions it looks very very
tired what is all that that's if
somebody wants to throw roses on the bed
oh for God's sake isn't that
adorable and then they go back in the
drawer I guess you used
them okay well I'll look forward to
seeing you downstairs I'll have lunch
super thank you you're
welcome
wow
Jesus that's
freaky the owner's bedroom is literally
a meter away the place is so dated what
a
mess
[__] just
cluttered what a mess
look at this
a I mean
seriously bloody hell piped with [__]
everywhere all
decorations
terrible right here have a can sit
wherever you prefer boom boom boom let's
get some food out you want to get some
food out yeah in
here Jesus Lisa let's junk everywhere
mhm yeah I know
everywhere is the whole house packed
like this of course it is why it's crazy
have you always been this bad it's a new
thing I'm coming at terms with right
it's just a but you do have a problem
with it actually no I I I think I've
actually gotten rid of a lot of things
in the past couple years don't have a
problem with everything I've just seen
in the last 10 minutes well oh well you
go right let's uh oh jeez and do you
know how to sell these how' you
pronounce that
s you've been here a long time you must
have the lingo S A lot of people must
point to what they want to order right
or just pick up the last line how' you
pronounce that uh conning bger kops wow
and how long's this uh menu been running
like this uh since the beginning oh 13
years ago stop seriously yes uh let's
start off with go for the sculps okay
let's do the beer batter the sourkraut
yeah let's go for that um and throw the
vegetarian mushroom ravioli in as well
wonderful okay great I'll keep a hold of
the menu for now okay thank you sear it
in first whoa yeah almost lost it
regroup
regroup where is Missy I'll bring it
right now that's Mr Ramsey's first red
pepper Blanc yes
sir our sear diver scallops with a red
pepper BR block wow thank you and
scallops are normally round right yes
they are we have beautiful sea scallops
I'm not sure why they cut it up today no
nor am I oh well excellent okay thank
you very much look like the dogs chewed
them I mean
seriously that's
rancid what's up with that excuse me
would you like me to give me any
comments back to the shop comments yeah
those [__] thank you terrible well have
Val take care of it for you who's Val me
I like the way you talk about yourself
and the third person sear diver Scot
tastes like [__] tastes like [__] really
wow okay any specific kind of [__] or
just no
diarrhea these here are the sauerkraut
bak and are these edible flowers or not
they are chrysanthemum they are mhm okay
great thank you all
right there
righta they are terrible I mean the food
is so so dated it's
extraordinary like a pair of camel's
bollocks this I have here is the
mushroom cream
delicious Taron cream w i mean what a
[__]
mess there she is [__] out wow vow
yes
delicious I mean Fu you kidding me no no
I'm [__] delicious seriously
really good now the flowers I'm all
about ah you had me go in there for a
whole second I thought it was all about
the food I maybe next course Jonathan
the flowers are absolutely delicious the
flowers and this menu doesn't change
every decade it's the same menu has been
on for 13 years Jonathan doesn't change
oh sorry I asked you a question Le
always anwers go on you Jonathan doesn't
change much Jes I'm sorry you you answer
Melissa's question first then I'll go
back to Melissa you said this doesn't
change but once a decade and I said
Jonathan doesn't change much
right um you've been here a long time
you've seen the place uh in Decline um
what's the big issues here little
disorganization um things unclear yeah
nothing consistent yeah and you know one
puts the other on edge and we get the
brunt end of it Lisa is listening to
every word you're saying I I can barely
hear you n was just talking to
miss okay I'm sorry Le no no do whatever
you need to
do um what's the worst thing she's ever
done to you uh smack me on the back of
the head in front of the customers
seriously in front of the customer not
hard but still uh
demeaning yeah I'll say damn said there
was under seasoned overseason under
seasoned really which
everything wow um where's Lisa I will
grab her for you right away Mr Gordon
and grab Jonathan too as well will you
please I will yeah and anyone else in
the kitchen please okay excuse me Lisa
Jonathan yes can we meet up in front
with Gordon that's the most edible thing
in
here uh right um First Impressions I
look outside historic in unfortunately
you've misspelled that it's prehistoric
everything's so dated I go up to the
room and the room shoddy Jonathan do you
not think it's a bit weird that a my do
open adjacent to your bedroom but your
wife's clothes are in my
closet I never thought of it that way
but I guess that is weird that was
shocking you just served me one of the
worst lunches I've ever
eaten and it was that bad I started
eating the edible flowers you can't be
proud of what you've just served me and
charged me ABS not absolutely not you're
correct you clearly have given
up it tastes like it and it feels like
it what do you think we should do
clothes because your heart's not in it
and I think your head's just in with the
clouds
embarrassing pretty [__]
awful it
sucked caught me off guard
completely I mean you knew he was coming
I
did really
embarrassing I really thought we tried
harder
and I let you down I'm sorry you did let
me down I'm really
sorry I always try to tell you that we
need to change things we need to make
him sexier and you never want to listen
to
me I've always wanted to change and you
always say I'm too random and it's not
I'm not random I'm trying to show you
ideas and things that we can do
differently it sucks he couldn't have
cooked worse than he did can you pull my
ankle it hurts so much I'm never going
to be able to walk tonight oh God don't
worry about it we'll be fine we'll
figure something out doesn't [__]
listen to me does he I feel so
good I'm not really that upset I'm just
crying because I want to right now I've
heard rumors around town that the
basement is known as a Swinger's hangout
and is used for late night parties so
before dinner service I want to take a
look at what's
downstairs wow look at
this my
God some really expensive stuff this is
crazy I can't believe how much stock
there is here it's like they're spending
the money in all the wrong
places look at that this place goes on
and
on oh my
God please shout before entering the
mineral spa mineral
spa oh my
God this is like a dungeon dungeon for
swingers tonight is crucial
because I need to get my eyes on how
Jonathan and Lisa are running the hotel
since both of them seem to be on
different pages can I get you beverages
to start with we're getting some wine
okay I was I was thinking Cosmos but
wine is
great there's so much stuff in here I've
never seen a kitchen so cluttered it's
been worse believe it or not how come
the food just sits there right at the
moment our timing is really not at all
good what are these for Jonathan those
are little premal little cracker little
piece of cheese premal
I get that too to get rid of please uh
to get rid of yeah I trash oh you can't
serve that of paper for customers to eat
you can't ask them to dip into a [__]
doily with a cracker and then a flow Yum
Yum Yum Yum it's just no it's a bit
[__] up Joy it's not your place but
it's just a bit
weird you okay yeah no I'm fine I'm okay
when with the chicken's roasted 2 days
ago that's the last of them why do we
roast them 2 days in advance they're
delivered twice a week they're cooked
off the delivery day what kind of
impression do you think you're sending
out to your customers when that
chicken's roasted two days before they
come I I I
I when do you think this chicken was
roasted oh my goodness I hope it was
today it was roasted 2 and a half days
ago go I am not happy to hear that at
all that was going to be dry as a dog's
bone but anyway uh try to enjoy okay
thanks I don't feel well anymore thank
you I will try they've been coming for
12 years you need to just seriously just
focus on getting this night done and
they sit there all schmuck I want to
kick them out right now do you want us
to take the food back I mean this is
like so disappointing that you guys feel
this way I thought we were friends and I
I thought you would maybe told us if you
felt the food sucked that much you know
it's really gosh I feel I feel like I
want to pass out right now [__]
know um so the lady you just talking to
her over there had no idea her chicken
was roasted 2 and 1 half days ago it was
roasted 2 and 1 half days ago yeah I
didn't know that okay fine it's not my
business with him just I'm just God you
two are so defensive there's a thousand
different ways to make
Str nothing to do that I'm talking about
the chicken I mean I'd love to find out
the prop chicken I'm talking to about
the chicken yeah well
make an excuse again Focus nothing
resonates with you does it nothing it
certainly does absolutely it all
does
what in the hell I just wanted to keep
it together tonight that's
all crazy are you like manic to the
company I'm manic yes I am right
now how's it going guys uh something
between shitty and awful what does it
mean when you feels like an elephant
sitting on your chest oh you don't have
a heart you can have a heart attack are
you hungry Gordon what is
this that is bacon should be on a
different shelf and this here that
shouldn't be thrown there
either what's that beer batter for the
beer batter shrimp should be thrown
out and this one let me just St that on
top sure put it right on top what is all
this that was
bacon I no no that's okay no why is it
in your fridge like this I dropped it
one shelf below instead of putting where
it belonged I put it on the corner
normally these things are pretty orderly
this is a complete cluster
F that Barn
beef let's let's get outside let's get
outside what is going on the whole
operation is screwed the kitchen
shocking the line disaster
cross-contaminated raw meat cooked meat
[__] everywhere and then the biggest
asset where all the money is is
downstairs in the wi Celler who's
maintaining standards here he is I
cannot believe what you just done in
there I really enjoy it you can't enjoy
that I swear to God I do I I must be
like cucko in the head or something well
you need help maybe he does you need to
wake
up
[__]
man I think we can do this I know we can
do this yeah but not just you and you I
want it to be you and I because you so
don't listen to me most of the time like
when I tell you it's time to come home
Jonathan it's time to [__] come to
bed and you just say [__] you well you
know [__] you now [__] you Jonathan oh
yeah I love you so much and you're such
a great guy but you suck as a business
partner you really suck thanks do you
want to recreate this you want to divor
I don't want to get divorced you want to
get divorced no I don't want to get
divorced why has it always been your way
I guess I've asked you know more than me
apparently I don't I'm as stupid as you
think I am if not worse thank god let's
go in the back
door [__] me okay give me a drink I
couldn't get this down fast
enough that looks pretty good all
right nice
[Laughter]
Dr it's going to be okay thanks for
being on the other side we appreciate
it oh
sorry that bourbon was really
strong
crap crying again it's not really crying
it's just really releasing release it
Lisa can you and him together please
sure I'm unconvinced and I've never met
a couple so undeserving of my time and I
think you Lisa you're just faking
it I'm just trying to no trying to get
through the night tonight no you're
acting the crocodile tears are there
next minute is a laugh it's
self-preservation and it's the only way
for me to get through the day there's no
heart there's no feeling a lot of heart
no there's not I love what I do no and
what do you love drinking with your
friends I don't do much drinking I'm not
the party girl he's the party boy so
there's no parties way on after service
downstairs in the basement with the
customers not in the past like 10 years
Jonathan you've lost
interest I'm a mess yeah you
are so the first thing I want you both
to do is to pack a bag I want you to get
out of here
start
packing after sending Lisa and Jonathan
away for the night I'm hoping they can
start to realize the effects they are
having on the Vienna but before they
return I called a staff meeting morning
good morning morning so I can get a
better understanding of the damage that
Lisa and Jonathan are
doing um I didn't get chance to meet you
yesterday yes I'm Jamie do the
housekeeping here okay great let's get
one thing right I'm here to help having
done my research I mean the one positive
feedback I've had is about how good the
staff are cuz I know you know just how
bad things are and having witnessed that
service last night uh I'm appalled is it
always like that yes screaming yes can
hear them in the dining room I've had
tables that have asked um if everything
was okay in the kitchen we can't be
expected to be professional all the time
time when they're not professional after
our shift they they'll sit down by the
table and expect us to wait on them hand
them drinks till midnight if we leave
they get upset so guests stay here and
they're drinking downstairs in front of
those guest sometimes with the guest see
there's no separation between business
and personal when you're sitting here
entertaining your table she'll find
something wrong that you're doing and
she'll come and point it out at you
right in front of your table table she's
just rude she texts me sometimes really
rude text messages like oh you forgot
this you forgot that or why didn't you
do this and why wasn't this time this is
crazy another problem that we really
have been having is we don't have an
actual payroll system there's no payroll
system and then they'll say yeah I'll
get you one and he just never ask him
for your salary we have to ask for we
have to ask for check yeah I got I got
20 bucks right now that's all I got
right now here tomorrow morning I'll see
you they're drip feeding your salaries
my bank does not take the checks neither
does mine when was the last time you had
a staff meeting and discussed this never
never uh I'm sorry but I want to put an
end to all this here's what we're going
to do um they're arriving any minute now
and my message to them is if they're not
prepared to bring in a level of
professionalism and understand those
boundaries need to be met on a daily
basis they're going to lose the in and
they're going to lose you and be going
to get
them I let myself continue to be abused
they need to know that it has to change
and it can't just be brushed off
anymore uh I had a chat with the team
they're not in a good good place and
you've abused Them There Are No
Boundaries they're your staff and they
need to be treated a certain way let's
go to Jamie
first I'm really concerned about the
abusive text that you send him why would
you send him an abusive test like oh you
would send me a picture like oh you
forgot this or you didn't do this right
or you told me that you worked at a lot
of other places and you knew how to
clean and when the toilets aren't
cleaned and stuff it's really important
but some of that stuff doesn't work so
it's like I'm sitting there scrubbing
and nothing's coming up and you'll be
like well go do it again and it's like
I'm trying I'm trying to do what I can
none of these talented individuals get
paid on
time I want to know why they don't get
paid on time because I don't have a
payroll system in place right now well
that's a [__]
disgrace that is
disgusting and then you want them
waiting on you up until all hours of the
early morning while they t up after your
crap and then you can't even be bothered
to pay them on time it's
a it's a mess no you are a
mess I need to say something though that
almost every single person here we've
given them loans you're lending them
money to buy uniforms to work in your
goddamn business right that's absurd why
why absurd to pay for a uniform the
business should be providing the uniform
well maybe we need to do that I never
thought about it that way whose business
is
this I've tried to create here a place
where people can come and and and relax
and escape from their stressful lives
escape from their stressful lives to
hear you and Lisa scream at each other
are you [__] kidding
me we don't always scream at each other
but when we do I'm that's smallest place
is you live here so you've got no idea
how many times you do it
the love affection and respect that
they've shown you is extraordinary and
the sad news is you both don't deserve
it I'm
sorry I will change I just hope you you
guys want to
continue I just want to say thank you
for your honesty uh loyalty uh there's
some other important people I want to
introduce you to this morning uh thank
you thank you thank you very much thank
you
guys uh good morning ladies and
gentlemen morning good morning uh So
Lisa and Jonathan uh I've asked uh some
ex- customers uh locals to come and give
you some feedback has anybody stayed
there recently we did the room we stayed
in it had tools and screws and
instruction manuals
so it's not just for the air
conditioners and stuff yeah that's right
you're right Madam give us an insight to
your experience please I do have to say
my husband ordered uh scallops and they
were raw we returned them the decor was
very outdated and it feels very
cluttered you feel like you're locked in
the closet it's just overwhelming when
you're trying to have a nice dinner I
would never come back there if things
don't
change okay what do you guys think about
the uniforms it's a bit much the poor
ladies were kind of
revealing our server was the nicest
person but I think it takes a lot away
from them it doesn't need to be in your
face the reputation locally is crucial
what have you guys heard I've heard
that's a Swinger's hang
out I heard that as well when I had
mentioned the Vienna they said that's
where the swingers
go you eat downstairs and then you go
upstairs is what I was told
but you've heard this
before we've heard it for 13 years but
is this due to your late night drinking
and the party I don't think so fact or
not that's how you're living there but
what I'm trying to say is that there are
no boundaries it's a Oasis down there
that has got a Jacuzzi a massage table
and if the word has gotten out around
town and then you people misunderstood
that room and that's where it all
started I'm just saying it either a
business
or it's your home there's no there's no
crossover the mixed messages you're
sending is your own fault cuz you
haven't been
clear I used to come to the restaurant
probably every month or so and I can
tell you have a lot of like passion for
your heritage but it's not in the food
anymore if Gordon can help you take your
heritage and the food and modernize it
and you can progress with that I'll come
every Friday mark my my words it's a
promise do you have anything to say both
you to these guests thank thank you so
much for your honesty and input and U
really really appreciate it we're going
to be making some big changes to uh
address many of the things you talked
about the staff have been incredibly
loyal they haven't been treated the way
they should have been treated I'm
undecided about these two but I am
committed to that team cuz I see what is
at stake and the Jeopardy they face
going forward now I got some something
else important to sort
out after leaving Jonathan Lisa I moved
forward with my plans to help renovate
the Inn I brought in selia Dave Foss to
create a beverage program you just have
a look in here I mean that one's
fantastic from the excessive infantry
they weren't using O3 oh that's
delicious my team worked up to the last
minute transforming the many spaces at
the Piana
wow wow that is amazing holy smokes this
is beautiful this is
incredible Bravo the Vienna had no
Organization for managing their
day-to-day operations so I gave them the
state-of-the-art system to help with all
their hotel operational needs welcome to
the web res Pro system and this will
help transform your business it will
link up to the POS system and it will
give you data like you've never had
before fabulous you need to be organized
from the infantries to the wage costs to
the salaries to the PS systems to the
checking in and the checking out system
and the good news guests can now book
online so this should relieve a huge
headache I could see that everyone was
thrilled with the changes at the Vienna
good have a good look round but as I
watch Lisa where's this stuff from I
noticed she was dissatisfied with the
renovations these are different chairs
from the other ones aren't they no I was
just seeing if it was 100% cotton eggs
is that a pull out no it doesn't need to
be a pull out and right now I'm worried
where Lisa's head is going into to
relaunch this
[Music]
evening good evening I can help you with
your bags of first get you checked in
while it was time to relaunch the inn
and restaurants a little more modern y
we have an order I provided the staff
with brand new uniforms that go with a
new updated menu that includes wine
pairing and beer flights first is going
to be the Greatful then the second is
going to be the
pser are up here please get out of here
Lisa off the line actually let's turn
this lamp
on no light bulb oops
excuse me see jaming no light bulb in
there I just wanted to turn my light on
don't worry about it okay what who's
complaining about the light bulb just
making sure that they have enough like I
trying to turn it on then realized it
later doesn't matter doesn't matter
let's focus on the big things are you
always like this over little details
like that I like to have things feel
right and so I'm feeling extra like an
extra need to make sure everything's
right that's all Ot cler Ot probably
whatever that means over the top
well over the top I guess I don't have
to be so over the top now do I you do
not what is wrong with her tonight do
you think she's going to go back to her
old way when I leave she might
accidentally customer's coming welcome
while Lisa is nitpicking everything
unnecessarily do you guys have the
appetizer for table five oh sorry we
didn't give you that yet no you didn't T
5 no no Jonathan oh [__] is lost in the
kitchen and service is starting to
suffer what table number is this please
that is table number 11 and waiting on
the two flank steaks with it and where's
the flank steak are they coming uh
moments moments uh minutes who's cooking
the flank steak come on guys we can do
one four top at the same time yes yes I
designed the menu around the size of the
kitchen and the speed of both you
working together
okay come back for the flank what the
hell is this look at me both you both of
you cut the [__] okay look at me you're
more capable of doing four [__] main
courses at the same time especially when
there's two of you and one of those main
courses is the same dish we got to talk
to each other but I'm not going to start
sending one dish at a time from a four
top serious doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at
all Jonathan but look at me hey look at
me I need some [__] effort from you a
little bit I need a little bit of
respect and a little bit of effort from
you okay yeah and look at me you're the
man holding this [__] thing together
got it and if you go down the whole
[__] place is going to go down so I
need you step up okay I need to talk a
little bit and I want four main courses
at the same [__] time and Jonathan
you can get your mind set round four
main courses at the same [__]
time understand we're serving one table
at a time and we're going to complete
that table yes four main courses three
main courses five main courses going
talk together yes goes with what the two
soups what's coming next it's going to
be uh sausage two carrot soups and a
fried cheese good for table seven okay
so we're talking now yep good carrot
thank you very much we have your flank
steaks your wine is coming right away
okay your sausage you guys are all
sharing right I think the New Vienna
will definitely attract a younger crowd
oh my God so beautiful I'm super excited
about the new changes and I hope they'll
last I I really
do uh right we've had ups and downs but
tonight is a prime example of how good
and how profitable this business can be
customers loving the food they love the
decor I'm leaving you with all the tools
to get this place back to where you
wanted to go I do want to ask you one
thing sure is there anything that's
happened this week that you're not happy
with yes I had expected the bloom Z to
be done not the coning but I was it was
the room I didn't expect and the room
that we've done is amazing still has
problems can I just tell you something
really important this is not a makeover
show I know that yeah but you're
complaining about I wasn't saying I
didn't love that room it'd be a great
shame for you to sound ungrateful oh I'm
not ungrateful I am just so the new
management system to Dave you've got no
idea com across wrong if you think that
I'm being ungrateful cuz I'm really not
it sounds like that no not at all I
can't come in and wave a magic wand and
transform 15 bedrooms and put a brand
new kitchen you now know what needs to
happen I do but I need to tell you
something that you're not going to like
I arranged for a new stove you did to
come and then when I got the engineer to
come and Survey the place unfortunately
he had to leave yeah because he was
going to shut the place down there's
practices that are taking place in there
that aren't appropriate you're saying
the gas systems or the whole setup
underneath there nothing's been changed
in 13 years and it's on the verge of
running legally okay
mhm listen I came here to help but you
need to help yourselves and you need to
dig deep and stick together
okay thank you thank you good luck okay
thank you Gordon okay good night thank
you I'll feed is in safe
traveling man that's hard
work soon after I left Lisa and Jonathan
reverted to the old Vienna this is
something that belongs here that came
with the house what are you doing you're
insane by changing the decor and
bringing back the original menu it's
worse than it was it looks horrible they
chose not to take my advice about
running the in properly listen to me
about what should be going on in the
kitchen and as a result their reputation
in town Remains the
[Music]
Same I'm checking in to Historic brick
hotel in Newtown Pennsylvania where I
meet an overbearing owner who has run
her business into the ground no no no no
no no no no no no and what was once a
proud
Landmark are they bullet holes in the
wall That's MO is now suffering from NCT
this place is
disgusting the road ahead is not going
to be easy for me I try to get through
the owner who's totally
oblivious
[Music]
30 mil north of Philadelphia lies the
burough of Newtown Pennsylvania home to
this historic brick
Hotel owner Veranda qua a former
therapist bought the property in 2006
with her son CJ who serves as a silent
partner in their business we bought the
brick Hotel because it was an investment
opportunity when we first purchased the
place we were told that it was going to
be a sort of a hands-off
it'll run itself you just have to watch
it of course we had no
idea zero idea what this business is
about I always said to my son maybe this
year we'll make a profit maybe this year
we'll make a profit and it never
happened she used to be in Family
Therapy so patients comes with that job
and I've seen her have a short fuse
where she wouldn't do that um before we
B the place when I came here blew my
mind away that you're still putting in
money so I cut out a lot of stuff here
and it really annoyed and irritated
people and they basically started the
dislike
verar
plan it has been a bit of a dictatorship
here with vendar you know it's either
her way or not her way no no no no no no
no no no no no vendar is a control freak
she is involved in everything she will
not release or relinquish control ever
she has the ball you want me to put it
in she's not a people person she has no
people skills she just screams out
demands and she's very rude at times
Paul French onion on here now there is
such a turnover with staff that I don't
even know their names in 8 months I've
probably seen over 50 people go some
some people come in for one shift and
they listen to her for 5 minutes and
they roll right out the door I wish I
had two clones of
me and believe me this place would be
hopping I feel the brick might have
become like the laughing stock of new
town so the reputation around town is
that you know no non they call me the
crazy lady which is fine to me you know
what if I'm crazy because I'm trying to
save the business so be it I think we're
at that point where this is really our
last chance if we don't figure something
out it's either sell it get rid of it
because we can't sustain
[Music]
it before I came to town I heard the
brick Hotel had a high turnover rate so
I had my team reach out to former
employees so I can get some information
before checking in uh first of all good
morning good morning I've never met such
a large team of EX employees uh small
showing this is a small showing oh yeah
what there's more there's a lot more
hundreds hundreds hundred I would say
hundreds um how much turnover is there
with staff when I left vindor had been
through almost 50 managers 15 50 50 50
managers 50 and the biggest problem with
the place is what
vindar she's been coel to people I
watched her and she's she's mean and she
can be a bully and I've seen her reduce
people to tears wow that's terrible you
know there's so much neglect between not
only the staff her managers but her
customers as well
seriously I couldn't take it anymore I
worked the holiday season and it was
kind of like the last Str off for me and
what made you quit I worked all of those
parties through the whole month of
December I was lucky to receive some
payback like in February with your tips
yeah she'll cut you a check in 6 weeks
when she feels like it she wouldn't let
you go pick up your paycheck she called
the cops on you you said she called the
cops on you oh all the time numerous
times seriously called the police
because you wanted your money you
threatening her seriously I mean it
sounds like a dictatorship as opposed to
a boss that's there to support loved it
there it was very Homey the opposite of
now all the locals came we had a booming
Hotel business wow it was such a great
place and then the quality just steadily
went downhill and I think she had a
complete lack of respect for the staff
and didn't understand that your staff is
a huge
asset what a mess can I ask a question
please have you met her oh no at least I
just arrived seriously think you are in
for a treat I was curious just by the
way you were speaking because I thought
he hasn't met her yet has he no no no so
calling the cops you know High staff
turnover um standards dropping I haven't
got much confidence however I'm going to
tackle it head
on you don't look very optimistic do
you I thank you wish me luck thank you
take
[Music]
care wow look at the size of this
place oh dear why happened
there
damn when did that happen you know it's
been here since I've been here oh really
hi I'm Aran this place good to see I get
a bit nervous when I check into the
hotel and the windows are
smashed um anyway how are you I'm good
thank you I'm happy to be here are they
bullet holes in the wall uh you know
they might very well be I'm not sure if
they are we're 250 years old so 250
years old mhm uh what's wrong with the
place I think it's beautiful place but I
think it really just needs need some
upgrading and uh which part's beautiful
help
me selling up the entrance with the
smash Windows well I think it could be
beautiful it's been neglected for a
while what happened here
oh oh
my oh
my that looks much better wow dear oh
dear I don't know if render's not going
to be too happy
you just ripped the wallpaper done that
was fantastic what time is the calling
in she might be here I can check I'd
love to meet her oh he's bringing vendor
up vendor
Hi how are you good how are you very
well a little nervous the smashed glass
what happened there it's been there
since before I bought
it how long we had the hotel 10 years 10
years and you didn't think about
replacing it first impressions customers
walking through the door it's it's the
have you been
drinking you look like I
drink did you run a hotel before you
bought this 10 years ago yeah never
never now what did you do therapist for
children I did that for 20 years that
was my practice wow okay uh 2011 I'll
see you uh shortly I'm going to go and
check in and uh unpack
okay place is
filthy
woman the [__]
Maran I I need a rag uh napkin or
housekeeping
please God mine
what is that
oh oh Jesus let me get housekeeping for
you housekeeping call the fire
brigade h hello are you the housekeeper
I'm not I'm looking for I'm I'm Caitlyn
Caitlyn please meet you so my hands are
dirty so I'm just going shake hands I
don't want shake hands like that sure no
when was the last time this place was
cleaned there's dust and [__] everywhere
uh T is here every day uh so I would
assume Right cleaning I mean under here
look I'm not talking about a couple of
weeks of dust I'm talking years and
behind here as well look hi hi oh jeez
how are you oh hi are you you good yes
I'm fine fine right what do you do
housekeeping stop which house this house
come over look at the mess down there
what's that what's that Fab let's get
the place clean fabulous let's just have
a little test
here look at that look at that do you
have a program that you clean floor by
floor a
program no no uh where is my room to
what is your room no what's that up
there who sits
here is it a [__] tea party for rats
or Stuart Little in for dinner tonight
what the [__] is that oh what is it like
pet
corner we drop our cats off for dinner
here Jesus man who does this you care to
join me come
on go for
it come on let's let's sit in the friend
let's talk about your cleaning habits
take I think I can fit right here no no
I my my butt's way bigger than yours
take a
seat may we have some menus please oh
sure yeah absolutely so what in the [__]
is going
[Music]
on I actually said something about that
but you
know you
comfy absolutely not no all jokes apart
forget the mice party Tea Party St
Littles [__] hang out what is the
biggest problems here cuz I'm things
like this the mold the the mold who who
we got rid of the Dust what do you mean
the mold where's the mold
oh right yes take take me to the mold
okay thank you EXC start this way but
where let's go this way
first
M so I guess it starts I don't know
exactly where it comes but it comes from
somewhere on the shower curtains I ask
if can we change it is you tell the own
to change these out yes sir and any
response she'll get to it oh look at
this look at that come
over is that MO that is mold yes I said
that that's
mold see it mhm bloody how when was all
the linen last changed look at the color
of this how much sweat is on there oh
man oh look at the color of that so
that's what that is sweat that's sweat
and then is that a is that a tube
television how
old have you ever heard of a flat screen
yeah I got five you've got five flat
screens at my
house what a mess what's that in there
what a empty box of tights silk
Perfections
Jesus does the owner ever come into
these rooms since I've been here I
probably seen her here maybe once once
upon a time these were white right you
see these look at the color of them how
gray and dirty dirty God they stink oh
you can tell this supped have been white
oh man I was worried about your eyes for
a second there where's my room please
2011 please tell me it's not worse than
this
one
2011 bloody
hell what a mess dust everywhere and all
this what is
this
terrible girl how you doing found all
The
Nasty no I thought that the curtains
were
gold no for real they were supposed to
be white oh my goodness I am
appalled and then just underneath it oh
right now it's pretty obvious that the
owner doesn't even put a scent back into
this room even into the
hotel but
when an owner can't be bothered to
change a smash window in reception I
don't hold much hope for the rest of the
hotel and look at that up
there what's that check out time 11:00
a.m. yeah I'll check out way before that
my
[Music]
love hi nice to meet you I'm Tammy
Gordon good to see you good to meet you
um and your sales and event coordinator
the brick rumors has it you do a lot of
events do a lot of events wow how many a
week on average about 350 a year it
sounds like this is the oxygen that's
keeping this place alive unfortunately
that's the truth wow what other problems
are there help me uh Staffing
is terrible why are there so many staff
going through the door what is it um or
randar is firing them often I'll come in
on Monday and see who didn't make it
through the weekend she's very tough to
work for the bottom line is the problem
is the owner yes there's nobody else
here starts at the top I appreciate you
honestly well we appreciate you being
here after learning the hotel's revenue
is strictly from events I want to see
how bad the food really is seasonal
local fresh I ordered a couple of items
the French Indian soup which was
tasteless that's so bad
terrible so I opted for something with a
little more
[Music]
flavor that tastes better then I ordered
something I've never heard of before a
cauliflower steak which by name I should
have known better that is a mess who put
on the menu binda and a crab sandwich
which maybe I would expect to be Frozen
but not from a can Product of China
fresh mm-m seriously are we done is
there did you've got your burger still
do you know what cancel it absolutely
cuz if it's coming from the same kitchen
forget it got it yeah tell the chef I
travel light I haven't got that many
[__] pairs of nickers thank you
oh my gosh oh my gosh he's freaking out
he's freaking out cancel everything else
no more no more he said
[Music]
enough uh take me to the kitchen
introduce me to the team place is
huge kitchen is
massive uh so where's the chef miss you
I'm not the chef you're not the chef you
nice to meet you are a chef though you
got a jacket on yes sir that's how Chef
10 to dress
Mao good to meet you too and this is bar
sex bar so you're the chef I'm not the
chef no you're the chef a chef but not
the chef a chef there's two of them
there's two of them the other ones are
where's the head chef well we have both
of them in charge no such thing your set
of rules your set of rules doesn't
benefit the customers I'll come back to
the food in a minute I'm in shock before
I got here I met a dozen of your
ex-employees okay I couldn't believe the
amount of staff that have left this
building in the last 2 years why are you
going through so many staff I don't know
you don't know I think I hire people and
uh oh so it's them not good enough for
you
yes when you have a young member of
staff that is owed money and they won't
leave the building till you pay them and
you call the police on them what kind of
business are you running here who said
that are you saying now that they're
lying please I don't know are you saying
they're lying simple yes or no I cannot
tell people cany it's inaccurate though
I do it's inaccurate yes I have
witnessed vendar call the cops on a
number of people she has a close
relationship with the New Town Police
Department do you care about this hotel
it's not funny I mean I I am not here to
laugh let's get that
right let's move on to my reception when
I walked in and there's dust and [__]
everywhere when I say dust I'm talking
dust that's been embedded for
years and there's mold on the carpet I'm
a little bit lost of words I ever sat
down in the restaurant and had dinner no
right top of your menu it's
fresh seasonal local it's canned food
I'm not a chef and I don't know all
these things what's wrong you feeling
sick no I need to take something out of
the oven sh you take it out the oven
what is this tomorrow's
chicken I see you
laugh what is this a game you have to
[__] wake
[Music]
up hi hiy guys how are you excited yes
we're checking in
no problem
bye-bye hey how are you Hi how are you
nice to meet you first name is I'm
Jessica Jessica good to see you I heard
you had a great time today great time
not but uh yeah let's wait and see who's
that that is CJ that is vend our son oh
hi CJ yes I'm one of the co-owners as
well good to meet you how many times a
week you're here I'm here right now
probably less than once a month even
I've got another job that I pretty much
a full time what did you do uh manage it
it w why did you buy this why did we buy
this it was an investment opportunity
when we first got into it we're told it
was TurnKey hands off so that was 10
years ago yes have you seen any return
on that yet zero zero when do you think
it's
coming well I have been talking about
that quite a bit over the last 6 months
because uh it's getting difficult to
keep putting money in wow in your mind
foret get him what's wrong with the
place I'm very sorry cuz I know this is
your mom but I can't I can't deal with
how she treats me it's like when we
don't need her here she's here and she's
on me about the smallest things
wow do you have one foot in their camp
or one foot in your mother's Camp um I'm
split between the two I've actually had
employees tell me why aren't you around
more because you're Pleasant to deal
with how's this going to get turned
around if she's still micromanaging and
dick hating to everybody about how this
place should be
run she says if she's not here it's
things will fall apart and it won't get
done that sounds
right any here customers hi guys how are
you good evening good how are you
welcome how are you you well you guys
have a reservation yeah Weinstein sorry
about the smash
window and the crabs from China CBS from
China okay to follow me no I don't go to
China for
crap
[Music]
gentlemen I have one order for you it's
just the first course on the first table
it's just two soup of days thank
[Music]
you okay who's
next I got all the soups all right first
thing is this it's a apple pear no blue
cheese and a eggplant
stack where's the Apple pair can we get
this out why is she doing this is she
always on the hot plate she is she's
never quiet which ones are done can you
guys take those down is this done no
I've taken my stuff down that's done
yeah wow it's a little
agrava guys waiting on the EG it's
coming it's coming we're working it hard
we making us nervous oh my goodness
Carly
Carly what I'm coming what is that put
this here take this this is yours no
that is my New York STP not this is
craziness who's doing the
cauliflower are you cooking the
cauliflower
now
yes I know I swear to God can you flip
this and what she do cooking I have no
idea did she normally cook yeah this is
crazy absolute
crazy
what a
mess wheels are stuck was just sliding
on the [__]
grease oh
God that is gross Brenda you got 2
seconds sure just stand behind there
will you oh my goodness just no please
stand behind there I'm
I'm what is
this Ma you guys just cleaned this is
this from
today I don't even know what's back
there vindor what when was that cleaned
it's they just cleaned it two days ago
they got spilled everything there come
here I know hand on heart that is not
from
yesterday that is not from yesterday
what's that up there seriously what's
your eyes watch your
eyes who cleans this
[__]
[Music]
who is it since I've been here no one's
cleaned it since you've been here no
one's cleaned it I appreciate your
honesty Miranda yeah they since he's
been here he's never cleaned it this
place is
disgusting and
this iord I don't come and do this you
don't want I trust them that they would
kill that
they you you guys cleaned the floor the
other day didn't you we cleaned the line
the other day we sweep the line you said
you guys took out I never said that I
never said stop stop you're just trying
to make excuses yes you are aren't you
embarrassed very at least you Tau the
[__] truth the owner's in
denial that has been pulled out for
[__] months that wasn't pulled
out what a [__]
mess what is this
bloody
hell holy
crap what oh my God what in the [__] is
[Music]
that oh my God what in the [__] is that
that's grease from the hood can you stop
lying that was not cleaned yesterday I'm
telling you this is grease from the hood
but they haven't cleaned it do you have
any any idea what happen if that caught
fire why not no do you have any idea if
that caught
fire I do what are you
doing you stop
caring no that's not true I mean I
that's the sign of an owner that
cares I want an answer I'm going
upstairs by time I come down I want an
answer CJ is he gone I don't know where
he went
Jesus oh my
God
right I'm unconvinced that this place is
clean so I want to run a quick bacteria
test it looks
disgusting and I don't think these vents
have been clean for
years time until did you talk to Ramsey
no he came down here looking for you and
she
goes now 10 to 20 is deemed as sort of
clean respectful anything over 30 is
unhygienic dangerous and this is
[Music]
reading [__]
573 come in you were looking for me uh
sit down what is that this is a very
simple hygi
test anything above 30 is in the danger
zone okay
573 from the air conditioning
unit I don't have an answer for that
sorry
that's CJ
573 let's do another one how long's this
chair been here I believe since we
bought the place have you seen the
stains on it see the stains there yeah
let's see what that says did you ever
stay here uh no I've never stayed here
you've never stayed here in 10 years no
wow so you bought a hotel you invested
in it with Mom and you've never stayed
here I'm
amazed
446 and you've got no idea it's like
this what's the bathrooms like oh my
god do you know the shuns we got mold on
them no I did not your housekeeper
pointed it out those hair is there at
this rate I really should be wearing
gloves oh
dear a shower
[Music]
cut what
5,680 what in the
[__]
seriously
[Music]
I I don't have an answer for that at all
5,680 that is the volume of live
bacteria I'm going to wash my hands
[__]
hell 5,000 what in the hell's going
on I'm going to go and just check
301 sorry distur are you well I'm so
sorry do you mind list we got some
issues downstairs and found some pretty
horrific stuff I know you get ready for
bed I'm sorry that's okay I honestly
didn't think they were going to put
anyone in here today [__] I'm right look
inside that's mold underneath no you did
not did no you did not
really that is disgusting and I did a
bacteria test I've been doing them all
day on my shower curtain was mold I just
took a shower [__] we just give me 2
minutes okay oh my
[Music]
God what a joke this is insane fck I'm
done let's go come on let's go oh no oh
my God leave your bags there make your
way down to the front please leave the
phone it's not important customers are
way more important leave the phone alarm
customer out customer out go out Barry
drop what you're doing go off the
premise please we're not going to be
serving this anyway quick let's go you
got to move faster now let's go
everybody stand at the front just wait
two seconds is everyone out this isn't
the drill oh my God first of all I just
want to apologize there's no
fire more importantly over the last 3
hours all I've done is a bacteria
test oh my God I want to apologize to
all of you but I want to stop right now
while I try endlessly to get through the
owner who's totally oblivious is that
the owner this is the owner we all ate
here we were all playing on staying here
and you're smiling like a smirk on your
face what I'm not going to do is just
allow this lady to laugh at me you guys
to pay good money and eat and I'm
certainly not letting pay guest stay to
sleep here I'm done my team will assist
you getting yourself out of there relax
there is no fire but we are not going to
continue I want to stop right now and
shut this place down oh my God oh my God
I'm so
sorry I need you
now thank
[Music]
you when are you going to get
real when are you going to stop close
the [__] door and take a good look at
yourself in the mirror if I say anything
it's not believed so what's the point
what do you mean it's not believed what
is wrong with you I can what is wrong
with you what is wrong with you there's
nothing wrong with me it's just after 10
years I'm here every single day they
don't like me and they insult me and
they disrespect me every second they
work here they steal from me they're on
their cell phones for 4 hours a day you
disrespecting every member of staff
you're blaming everybody for what you've
created somewhere you s Switched Off and
ignored all the problems and took it out
on the staff is that's what they're
telling you yes that's what they're
telling me right now I'm going to tell
you something you've never heard
before you're out of your
[Music]
depth last night after shutting down the
hotel and seeing Veranda had no
communication with employees I organized
a staff meeting anyone down
there but Veranda was nowhere to be
found there you are there we looking for
you they said that youd run away no I'm
not running away I
don't you don't want to meet in front of
the staff why
not my biggest problem is that you have
shut down and you refuse to let anybody
in I walked through the w those people
steal from me every single day and so
you had some incidents with some bad
staff years ago and then you think
everybody that comes through your door
is is is it's exactly the same no
they're not it's not about a oneon-one
anymore you can't just focus on one
individual and you've done that
brilliantly in the previous career
running a team managing a hotel is
completely different all right okay we
need to get the team back on side and
they need to believe in you and you need
to believe in them it's a two-way thing
well it's a process too it is a process
yeah but if you don't walk back through
those doors and face the music with me
then I'm going to go as well because I
can't do this without you I I don't know
how let me show you
[Music]
how uh well first of all um thanks for
coming in early this morning um listen
this is hard there seems to be a massive
conflict how do we get the trust back in
the room what would you like to see
change we just did a FAL last week 90
people and there was two servers zero
busers zero bartender well of course
it's a money issue it's a budget issue
so I took it over that is why we we we
had a schedule on Monday for the cooks
we come back Tuesday the schedule's
completely changed you do the schedule
but there should be the chef's job you
need to be responsible for your own
departments like Macy's responsible for
the kitchen Tammy's responsible for the
events you have to offload the work from
you and give them the responsibility
guess that's a mistake when was the last
time you all had a meeting we had a
service staff meeting in here that we
get yelled at and it just gets hostile
and people get up and me included and
walk out and it just doesn't yeah help
anything let's stop there we not not
this is why this is why no one wants to
no one ever say want man can't get your
voice but you must understand now that's
the wrong way to handle
things there seems to be a really bad
vibe in the room that we can't shake
off but if you want to clear the air
people need to turn their phones off
when they walk in and clock in and leave
something abouton I have said that
million times please do not bring your
cell phones in here and invariably I
come in a 2:00 I see you guys outside on
your cell phones that is a break never
see me on my cell phone out you okay
fine I mean you know maybe you're not
doing it but other people are doing it
why is there so much distrust in this
building it's the people stealing from
me drinking on the job doing shots over
here that's not now we're talking as if
it's today yes but there is I mean you
know aren't taking
shots but what I'm trying to say you're
you're accusing them of somebody else's
bad
practices what you need to stop doing is
blaming them for the
past can you trust your
team
yes tell them that okay I'll try please
but I can't I can promise I can only
try look at that that smile that will go
a long way we all know it's not going to
change overnight Sur process so we need
to embrace that process and we need to
install confidence I'm open to the
change that he wants me to follow if
there's what's going to make this place
a
success I feel like the St meeting was a
step in the right direction vandar seems
to be coming around but I want to make
sure she is 100% committed morning uh
thanks so much for coming I really need
to talk to CJ privately because he's the
one person who can help get through to
her uh CJ I'm going to be honest I'm
going to be up front I'm not dealing
with a hotelier um I'm dealing with your
mom um and I'm sure she holds a special
place in your heart but unfortunately
she's running around like a dictator and
she's not letting any of the staff
breathe she's stifling the business I've
had conversations with her about a few
things similarly I've told her um the
way we were brought up and raised in
India that tone in conversation doesn't
work here and uh she's struggled to be
very honest adopting to that part of it
um you adapted brilliantly come to this
country but she's one tough cookie you
know that yeah she is nitpicking the
staff and then she's not giving any of
them responsibility she needs to be less
hands on okay and more supportive no I
know I
know this is crazy mid 60s she shouldn't
be running around like this no she was
very honest with me last week she told
me I want to spend more time with the
kids and my time is running out and I
haven't heard her say that ever right
but she needs to let go okay so how can
I help I need a commitment from you got
to be there to support it we need to get
rid of that Stu us from your mom and
make her understand that this business
can be fruitful she just has to step
back okay we can't continue like this is
do or die and we need to step up okay
all right I'm going to have a talk with
her today please we got one more shot at
this after spending time with CJ he
clearly sees the issues his mother has
and I have asked him to reinforce the
changes she needs to make what we should
talk about is how do you let go the
responsibility is Shifting which means
you don't run around doing things if
it's Mao's kitchen if you're making that
decision it's not your problem to deal
with let Jammy and the kitchen Chef do
everything P into the k i I had learned
it the hard way at my job I I was
working 70 hours a week mother yeah I
know but when I got the team in place
and I stepped away I only get involved
when there's an escalation
okay all right I mean you know I can do
that and you know what let's see what
happens with Veranda on the right track
the next order of business is starting
the renovation process the brick Hotel
needed drastic changes so my team work
through the night to get the hotel ready
for relaunch welcome to the new brick in
wow oh my god wow oh
wow Beau oh my goodness it's amazing
this is it
is would you like to come up and see my
room yes yes
[Music]
yes wow oh my
god wow oh my gosh I'm about to take a
nap I'm taking a nap I think I might
have to come check it
now
everything about these rooms are amazing
amazing wow I'm excited to come to work
in clean come on jump on that on jump oh
my God you do
it oh my goodness very nice thank you so
much you're
welcome after updating the brick hotel
with a modern look I give them a classic
menu that is perfect for the town and
can better accommodate catering for the
large scale events that take place at
the
hotel hi good evening welcome to the
brick hotel as for the relaunch I
invited the locals not only to dine at
The Brick how are the first couple bites
of everything oh fantastic these are the
best gos I've ever actually had in my
life but to tour the renovated rooms as
well my look at this oh my god look how
nice this
is while on the hotel side everything
has been well received the kitchen is
running smoother than ever me balls
arini Sprouts yes one time 86 brussel
sprouts yeah 86 brussel sprouts please
86 a good time thank you and with CJ
having a presence R brussel sprouts
should I go get them no no what do you
mean go get them he's able to prevent
his mother from slipping back into her
old habits it's okay let it go you said
it's a good sign a good sign yes now she
can focus on her duties as an owner
looks
fantastic
C was happy yes yes first of all it's so
nice to see you smile yes you had to
walk around this town with your head up
high well I apologize for the difficulty
I gave you initially okay and the only
thing I want to see you do is from time
to time come in here and walk around
like you did all night tonight with
charm and Grace I've told them that you
are banned from behind that line okay
car all right I promise you all the
stuff will happen promise me yes you
think you promise I'm not a person who
expresses Joy or in know you know
jumping up and down and things like that
but it's really really wonderful it's
given us a lot of oxygen for a second
life best wishes Take Care thank
you wow what a
[Music]
week after leaving the brick the
reputation of the hotel was on the men
CJ became a more visible owner and
Veranda stayed true to her word in
trusting her staff to do their jobs and
her employee turnover is at an alltime
low with these changes in place the
brick is well on its way to being what
it once
[Music]
was